Donald Trump was answering questions at
a so-called roundtable press conference
which basically means that carefully
selected sycophants are teeing up
softball questions for Trump it's sick
of inter sycophant I never knew that
like a fan is sick of sick of fant Oh
English is my second language give me a
break anyway they're teeing up questions
for Trump and Trump starts talking about
immigrants that are being deported as
being animals and as a side note if
you're watching the video
Trump's right eye is looking very very
swollen it's closer and closer to being
swollen shut every time I see video of
the guy anyway not the primary topic
here let's look at the clip and what
Trump had to say I cannot tell ice about
them we have people coming into the
country of trying to come and we're
stopping on a lot of them but we're
taking people out of the country you
wouldn't believe how bad these people
these aren't people these are animals
and we're taking them out of the country
at a level and at a rate that's never
happened before and because of the weak
laws they come in fast we get them we
release him we get them again we bring
them out so not only is this disgusting
it's also not true number one remember
that deportations are down under Trump
relative to Obama but number two
remember that Trump has been touting
that border crossings are down at a long
time low because his policy has scared
people out of even trying to come to the
United States so how can you
simultaneously say that people are
flowing in because the laws are weak and
we're deporting them at record levels
but at the same time we have fewer
people coming over because they're
scared about how they're going to be
treated because of the fright that he's
put into them with his retrograde and
xenophobic comments it's a mathematical
impossibility that both are true and
clearly at this point a comment like
this calling immigrants animals it's
just not going to register as anything
right this type of behavior and language
has been so normalized by the last three
years that note rumpus would
realistically bat an eye at this point
but can anyone really imagine any other
president talking about people who want
a better life in this way people who are
risking separation from their children
because they want a better life for
those children
that's what it means to be an animal and
this is now beyond any doubt I mean that
this is the language of an authoritarian
dictatorial type right there's no
denying it we can't soften the language
this is the humanization plain and
simple and it's one of the steps that
exists when we see authoritarian
dictatorship start to take hold in
history denying humanity to a group of
people equating them with animals this
is out of the textbook on pre genocide
'el movement and I'm not saying Trump's
gonna do genocide or that's what we have
under Trump but what I'm telling you is
that to the extent that he has a
philosophy of personal political
philosophy that actually is something we
can identify it's the way in which the
actions of people like Putin and Duterte
and Kim jong-un and air Dewan resonate
with Trump and the way that he
gravitates towards language that is the
exact same type of dehumanizing and and
really politically violent language and
that is the type of thing that you start
to see to prime people for the
acceptance of really terrible treatment
for those that you identify as being the
animals for those that you do human eyes
it's disgusting and sadly it's only like
the fifth biggest scandal for from
yesterday so you might not hear too much
more about it we have a fantastic
program for you today find me on Twitter
at D Pakman and find the show on twitter
at david pakman show today's episode of
the program is made possible in part by
Cody which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that wants to revolutionize how
we send and receive online payments cody
stands for currency of the internet and
the goal is to build an infrastructure
for online payments that simple
transparent trustworthy instantaneous as
well as scalable and today's payment
solutions have a number of different
trust and usability problems whether
it's between consumers or between
businesses or between consumers and
businesses and Cody wants to solve a lot
of those problems
through their currency and platform
which unlike a lot of the Kryptos and
blockchains that are out there have
actually been created specifically and
solely to be used for payments cody has
set out to do this by using innovative
base layer protocol in the form of a
directed acyclic graph based ledger
built from transactions connected
through time by harnessing trust based
algorithms if you're watching this on
youtube you can find out more about cody
and their initial coin offering in the
links below this video this is not
financial advice and everybody should do
their own research